hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to well I
got my recliner I got my I doughnut
doughnuts teacher Don that can only mean
one thing
our commercial yeah I guess it is a
weird idea to review commercials but
like I said before they lived in their
own little world and there's so much fun
to watch and laugh at the eighties and
nineties gave our childhoods some really
silly products and even sillier ways of
advertising them to us and guess what
we're gonna look at them again today so
welcome to part two of a look back at
nostalgic commercials and sing that I
like to call we'll be right back figures
that we started a girls commercial
fucking girl yes they just keep us from
our lust of plastic weapons yes you can
do everything with it drive-through
glitter pick up dangerous hitchhikers
pose it against that curious gigantic
city backdrop that you have for some
reason it's a girl's dream come true
actually the fun thing I realize about
this is that if that car was a little
smaller it'd be a boy's toy how weird is
that you think would be all about things
being bigger and stronger but no we like
them teeny tiny have you ever noticed
that girls got the huge convertibles we
got micromachines girls get the giant
detailed dolls we get the little GI Joe
action figures I mean at what point did
we look at TV and say fuck that tight
pussy convertibles this is a man's car
[Applause]
what was up at that girl's reaction it's
like she forgot she was supposed to be
impressed with the product she just
sounds so entranced too doesn't she
it's like all spring the products
suddenly turned to an incredible
superhero or something
what else can you say but Barbie Wow I
am he-man call Shira and me at one nine
hundred great another 900 number again
as if these didn't already have a sexual
slant by today's standards you honestly
have to put he-man in your ads now now
you're just doing the sexual undertones
into sexual overtones fabulous story is
about what I may or may not be wearing
will be revealed to you when you hold a
lock your mighty phone and say I got
[Music]
we'll also tell you how to get an action
figure or this colorful poster part of
your $2 35 cent two-minute call they'll
go to local science museums yes part of
your money will go to the Science
Museum's
we haven't figured out yet how to make
change for a penny but we'll figure out
some percentage it's not easy when
you're new in town he's new so we hate
him except when you have something that
makes huge bubbles amazing bubbles we
shit that kid has bubbles bubble thing
makes people curious
[Music]
I was so wrong to judge you Bailey how
can anything make bubbles as big as
giant as monstrous as bubble things
[Music]
nobody seems to be able to resist the
kind of bubbles bubble thing makes it's
like my cruel abusive family doesn't
exist anymore Thank You Billy you
changed my life forever look at bubbles
and what do they call this incredible
invention that brings people together
bubble thing Wow was the marketing guy
away from work that day a product it's
like calling transformers changey things
or GI Joes army and stuff or Hot Wheels
Union way to make us remember the
product guys bubble thing makes colossal
bubbles in its use from whammo hey what
you gonna do today Monty
I'm gonna call mine 7 6 M Jesus how many
of these call numbers were there this
one doesn't even look like it's try
they're gonna tell me a great story
every day I'm gonna ask my parents if
it's ok if I call 9 7 6 7 7 7 7
nah me first me first how much you wanna
bet this was just a local pedophile we
got on public access and want to hear
children's voices in fact what do you
think you are Sigmund
two dollars per call plus possible toll
ask your parents permission before
calling sega challenges you with
afterburner
oh hell yeah after bro was awesome the
excitement of the updated version you
know the only weird thing about this
commercial is the fantasies this kid has
I mean they're a little confused aren't
they Wow I'm playing a videogame that
makes me think I'm in a cockpit playing
a video game news dives supersonic speed
and radar London now only you can
convince Hulk Hogan that doesn't have
fucking aliens only on the sega system
sega the challenge will always be there
the system will not hey girls looking
for something more needlessly
complicated than Joe Crowe are you that
little bitch that oh it's needs to show
off to make yourself feel loved the kind
whose mother will threaten the coach's
family if you don't get a perfect score
this unnecessary addition to
overachieving physical perfection
yeah not to be fair maybe I'm being too
harsh I mean physical fitness is
important as long as you're not just
doing it to show when you've just want
to show up
[Music]
you
Oh God how did this toy never catch on
listen to this these were spacemen who
take over the minds of dinosaurs and
used them as weapons in their
intergalactic war TV show - but that
never went anywhere why I mean seriously
it's like the best combination of
everything boys like just throwing
Cowboys ninjas pirate and the annoying
of girls for making us feel confusing
emotions and it'd be perfect all I can
say is as long as Jeff Goldblum has
nothing to do with them these dinosaurs
awesome Tyrannosaurus Rex with figures
battle gear and motorized booking at you
die hey kids it's me the spring bunny
call me today oh come on that counts as
a reason to call a number because you
saw a fucking rabbit on screen there's a
new story every day so call today
I mean Hawaii Chinese - hello kids I'm a
tape would you like to hear an exciting
table adventure because you know tables
go on a lot of fucking adventures so if
you like to hear about me a table dial
this number table one we can't wait to
share our warm with a fun and
discoveries with you remember get your
parents permission before you die
preferably while they're asleep hey Fred
it's the same ol stick again
[Music]
stone okay I'm sorry I gotta address
something with these commercials here
you got Barney who's going to these
extreme lengths to get Fred cereal why
doesn't he just go to the fucking store
I mean my god it's incredible the
lengths he'll go to I mean his face is
on the fucking box
you think he'd be able to get a few free
wants everyone to know why for that
matter
why does Fred keep feeding into his
habit
what does he just crack and tell him
what he really needs to do bang oh this
rush got to roll okay Bobby
um before it chase you around as some
comedic routine I just want to ask you
to do one thing look at yourself just
really look at yourself I mean my god
Barney my god you're a pathetic wreck I
mean that stage a lot how much did that
cost you hundred maybe thousands of
dollars and you take doing this every
week week after week you blow your money
away when you could be spending time
with your family this is why you're
defaulting on your mortgage pawn this is
why Betty has to strip here there's a
$20 that's that's good for a couple
boxes don't don't let the storm
get up you enjoy yourself you have a
problem bond you have a real serious
problem and it needs to be addressed
I mean seriously bought what is it about
my cereal that sets it apart from other
cereals cuz it came from your wife's
books okay bye going down cereal part of
this nutritious breakfast do you ever
double delicious
[Music]
maybe it's me but this commercial seems
ungodly cool mr. turtle here's a classic
it has a great setup and a great
punchline it's a wonderful commercial
ask mr. owl mr. owl how many licks does
it take to get to the tootsie roll
center of a Tootsie Pop let's find out
one two three
sorry but you see I don't think that's
the real question here I think the real
question is why the hell is this boy
naked
nobody addresses this even the turtle
when he first comes out is like oh fuck
put on some clothes boy I could see your
chunk mr. owl how many lipstick cake get
beer scene I like is when the L opens
his eyes I don't know am I the only one
that finds that a little creepy mr. owl
let's find out well it's still a classic
commercial I always look forward to
watching it whenever it's up how many
licks does it take to get to the tootsie
roll center of a Tootsie Pop the world
may never know
oh yeah this is part of those McDonald's
commercials that try to advertise to the
teen demographic I guess they were
trying to make this a household simple
[Music]
yes this not only shows that you can do
1/4 of the YMCA song but also prove that
your mother drank while she was pregnant
with you seriously how the hell would
you react if someone just came up to you
and did this nothing much else you can
say but do the arches really we're
giving zelda on the mythical story about
a faraway land a rap song
[Music]
and the powers in my hand it's not even
the worst it's just the idea of giving a
fantasy game a rap seems really silly to
me
I mean you know Japan where the game
originated they probably treated with a
lot more respect
[Music]
well excuse me princess
it's like breaking okay yeah you know
how they always say that TV and movies
are riding your brain there's just too
much violence why don't you go play a
board game or something
yeah all right take a look at this board
greatness game because killing things
that are smaller than you gives you
power
oh yeah you all know this game and all
have a great time yes like most kids
though I always want to take the game a
little further is your person Jewish
yeah your history as your person's
looked with mommy is your person serving
time for multiple homicides yes is your
person the subject of several disturbing
documentaries yes two good cars do not
actually talk if they do you should
probably seek help now at Burger King
you can click Save the animal cards
really
you went from he-man cups that you're
supposed to swordfight wit two
environmentally aware trading cards
there's seventeen cards in four albums
one with every kid's meal and this is
why you'll never be as popular as happy
meals you can see women albums my heart
rate on With Friends actual odds of
getting raped by a gorilla in a Burger
King now only one in five
oh yeah
remember these commercials are we
starting the mentally tormented kid who
has a fucking fetish for a children's
cereal it always starts off with some
kid discovering there's no corn pops and
then we take a disturbing look into
their deep dark psyche if you were out
of corn pop out is my tell us corn pop
these kids are friggin nuts I mean if
you were watching this you think it was
something out of a scary film or a
psychological thriller or something
that's me the corn pops weird xkt right
sir no I want my Kellogg's Corn Pops
oops
let's go son coming go leave my corn
pops are you serious it's become all
like sweet popcorn there's never enough
and now if I work this bag on everything
and shag balls give it head and see some
Sun well they get deposited yesterday uh
popcorn pops Kellogg's Corn Pops is part
of this complete breakfast I got hot
searches high and low for fun food trees
is the fun fruit trees
I guess the idea behind these things was
that I don't know you make them laugh
and they drop fun fruit candies
that's why fun fruits are so much fun to
eat I don't know I always find these
things a little creepy I mean really
creepy
fruit-trees they just seem unnatural
every time they appear I keep think
they're gonna do something out of an
Evil Dead movie
fucking scam sub kiss fun foods every
chewy one is real rody fun oh boy better
enjoy this movie while you can folks
because you will never see it in
theaters again because no one know maybe
ravage back again on the big screen in
what give me happier classic margarita
did we mention that even though we're
just showing the enemy it sees there
only about this long is this commercial
that's right the rest is live action and
dealing with incredibly slow-moving
racial relations doesn't that sound like
fun kids blog a bit down where did you
now playing at a theater near you
warning this is Academy Award winning
movie Disney will soon be ashamed of it
may or may not be racially insensitive
honestly it's hard to tell but just he's
not gonna take that chance anyway see
the film that millions of people around
the world are calling ok your grandma
twin yeah they just arrived introducing
Cabbage Patch Kids twins it doesn't
happen very often
alright this is an ad for Cabbage Patch
Kids twins
[Music]
how is my Anna Marie
yeah it's innocent enough but look at
how this ad begins mom your grandma twin
yeah they just arrived no woman for the
sake of argument she didn't know that
was a joke if your husband called up and
said that your daughter is pregnant
would you react so pleasantly your
grandma Cabbage Patch Kids twins they
arrived together with special adoption
papers
how about Iraq you're admitting that
they have a part of it
remember the Wuzzles these toys were so
popular they've got their own Disney TV
show and who can blame them it's a
pretty clever idea
these were toys that combine two kinds
of animals like half hippo and half
wrong with these except for one right
that was okay really they couldn't come
up with something to rhyme with rule
that's gotta be one of the easiest words
to rhyme
I gotta Wasel I'm gonna snuggle so much
he can do see how it's incredibly easy
or how about I got a wazzle I'm gonna
snuggle we don't care about rhyming fire
shit oh it's still a clever idea
either way what's going on the story
book so flippantly from Hezbollah and
the weather for today will be Oh God
this boy is fucking nuts
heather's donor Barrow storm what hell
is this kid it's like he's in the lair
of a Batman villain rapid-firing
semi-automatic both hands hurt that
means six arrows no waiting yes
no waiting
that's why cause it's nurse or nothing
and by nothing we mean it's alright
aliens now we're talking it's the alien
fighting Queen gruesome gorillas
ultimate space marine wait wait wait the
ultimate space marine is named a tax it
sounds like discount tampons you get at
the dollar store tax disguised and his
big bad bug suit
oh really an alien disguise suit
why didn't they think of that before all
right Marines here's the plan we are
going to dress up in alien costumes get
a bunch of garbage bags and the world's
biggest dildos and we are gonna sneak
into the aliens nest they don't have any
eyes so they'll never be able to spot us
any questions
yes let's how do I get out of this
chickenshit outfit jump check in hips in
the heavily armored evac fighter blast
yeah
and my mom yes and bodily yes of course
the alien costumes and bottling this is
the future of our military folks this is
how it's gonna look
I think Hudson said it best by my
baggage sold separately you've got your
sunrise
you caught a prize you you're making
your Johnson what you caught a prize you
you're making your Johnson what pardon
Knights summer whites you your friends
and your Johnson Johnson Saturday nights
distant lights do your girl in your
Johnson whoa hey keep it clean
disturbing commercials get any creepier
than that rooster tails water trails you
your kids in your Johnson I'll slap you
you and your Johnson a way of life for
over 50 years and then your wife found
out what you were doing with your
Johnson and well let's just say you and
your Johnson will be hanging out with
any kids anymore which was like this do
make you wonder though are they aware
what's going on no I almost think they
planned this so that people will talk
about their products Awards like they
meant for it to have a double meet but I
don't know maybe I'm sounding like a
conspiracy nut I mean can you think of
any other commercial that can be taken
the wrong way so easily just when you
see what I've got it's the Wunder boner
the Wunder boner God you laugh now just
watch
he just assembled the Wunder boners
stainless steel rods like this take fish
and
[Music]
the Wunder boner introducing the Wunder
boner the amazing new fishing tool that
makes deboning fish a breeze okay you
have to know you're talking about
nobody's that naive you're trying to
play all innocent when you know that
everyone's gonna be snickering at your
commercial and thus remembering your
product better I mean I might believe
that it wasn't intentional if they don't
drop any more innuendos the Wunder boner
my wife would like that no you totally
know what you're talking about that you
should be ashamed of yourself
well I pick the Wunder boner is a winner
don't say that
I don't care of your wife with like one
of those just keep your fucking water
boner to yourself the Wunder boner comes
with a polyethylene storage case that
doubles as a base and a cutting board I
mean seriously you can't even say that
word without having somebody crack up
watch Wunder boner
[Applause]
you see
so hey did you get the wonderful buddy
you should order your Wunder boner down
oh all right kids
fucking Wunder boner - I draw the line
this was my look at commercials part two
I hope you had a lot of fun thanks for
joining me and I hope that you your
Johnson and your wonderful owner have a
fantastic evening I'm in this - your
critic end oh really
[Music]
my wife would like that